[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in albert brier
see your senior nfl reporter
i'm a little salty today here albert so
thanks for joining us here
but uh you've been yelled at before by
the nfl so uh you know i'm in good care
well
you know what that question actually
came up um because there was that whole
idea like
you know we were all asking these sorts
of questions in the summer
and i remember one of the questions i
had was well
you know with the stadium empty if like
say your offensive coordinator got it
wouldn't you be able to just put them up
in a sweep because nobody else is up
there
right like so wouldn't you just be able
to put him in a suite put a headset on
him
and have him call plays from there and
they said no to that
so i don't know if they think it's some
sort of slippery slope or whatever but
that was the policy that they sort of
gave everybody
back in august and september and i think
it relates to the whole thing you know
like how it's not allowed to have cell
phones on the sideline and everything
else i think it relates to that they
don't want the slippery slope but
you know i think what they probably tell
you is we can't just change the rules in
january
that's probably where the bevel crap
crack came from i'm guessing
we can't just change the rules in
january if we've been doing it a certain
way for four months
yeah i was just curious of the rule
itself i wasn't saying boy you got to
change the rule it's the playoffs
because i mean i certainly understand
this but um
i you know it it could only happen to
the cleveland browns
right if they finally make the playoffs
and then this happens
and i don't what kind of impact do you
think this will have on them where you
have
an all-pro offensive guard and their
offensive line has been their strength
this year
and then you lose stefanski who's been
wonderful with baker mayfield this year
i think it's i mean i think he should
have a big impact he's a play caller too
yeah that's the other part of it so now
you know alex van pelt who has been you
know a coach in the league for a long
time he
um got to the coordinator level in green
bay so you know it's not like he's
new to this but he hasn't been a
full-time play caller so that's going to
be an adjustment
you know that's an adjustment for your
quarterback too um
it's it's definitely i think it
definitely has an impact on what you're
doing because it stretches everybody
thin
you know so if you're taking away from
what alex van pelt would normally be
doing he's got to delegate that to
somebody else how does it affect your
defense
because nobody's you know you don't have
the same person overseeing the whole
game and game management
what sort of effect does it have on your
special teams you know with mike priefer
coming over and being the interim coach
so it's just
there are all these different kind of
pieces that
one fits into the other fits into the
other and your i think these staffs are
so tightly wound in the way game day
operation
works if you take the biggest piece out
you have to think it would have some
sort of effect
this just in the dolphins have announced
that chan gayley has resigned
as offensive coordinator i wonder about
you know his play calling or
like to uh trying to adhere to chan
gayley or
was chan gayley trying to adhere to tua
um you know it felt like the play
calling was a little bit different for
two and i don't know if that's just
that was chan gayley's philosophy here i
you know having talked to some coaches
who
you know went against them over the last
few weeks i the sense i got was there
were questions why they weren't going
down field more
and that they had been more aggressive
with ryan fitzpatrick in there and that
was something i guess that was
noticeable if you went back and you
looked like okay like what does it look
like when two is in the game when they
pull two
out what does it look like with
fitzpatrick in there and so
you know i i think the main question a
lot of other teams at least had was
is this a a reflection on the coach's
confidence into a
or b is it a reflection in his physical
ability and
and that's i think one of the big
questions going forward with him and i
don't know about you dan but you know
and i got this and this isn't just
coming from me this is from you know
people i talk to are paid to evaluate
this stuff
just sort of looks average physically
you know like i don't know that like you
you look at him go out there is there
anything elite does anything look elite
about the way that he plays now his
elite traits in college were
instincts accuracy feel for the game
and and maybe you know it's just tough
to show those as a rookie
um but i think that there's reason to
look at it and say god like they could
have had justin herbert there and now
they've got the third pick in the draft
and because brian flores and chris greer
have done such a good job
like i think you have to consider it and
i've talked to other people who again
get paid to evaluate this stuff who say
like you got to go in with a third pick
acting as if you don't have a
quarterback like you have to look at
those guys and evaluate them
and put them through the ringer justin
fields zack wilson whoever else you
might consider there
you have to at least take a look at
those guys now and compare them against
tua and so
the chan gailey thing sort of i think
fits into the bigger mosaic of where
they are
with tuatanga tungavalo and i think some
of the questions you have with tua
and not so much like you know what he
accomplished in college or who he was
coming out
but whether physically he's got the
ability to be an elite player at the nfl
level yeah he looks like he's
he's putting everything in his body into
these throws down the field there's
nothing that is
natural fluid where he just has a great
arm
i talked to a source last night about
two in particular because i said i'm
looking and i
and there was a replay of a game on and
he just had little dump off passes
yeah like that was the game plan there
was nothing that was stretching the
field
where he had that luxury with alabama
great offensive line great running back
and great coach and great wide receivers
there and that's where i don't know
and and the uh source said he he lacks
the um the danger the danger for the
defense to go
uh-oh we don't know what to expect but
my source also said
look if you if justin herbert didn't
have this year
would we be looking at tua differently
like
we're comparing the two and should we be
comparing the two
yeah because i mean that's like look
like
and i think there's a larger discussion
to be had here too
there are a lot of guys who've come out
of college the last few years that had
that
like that rap that they're raw right
like the big
physical kid and i think forever i don't
know about you but i feel like we've all
been sort of trained to be
leery of those players right like that
is this going to be jamarcus russell
you know it's just we have that kind of
idea in our head of what the big raw
athlete is you know what dan it's worked
out of late
josh holmes had patrick mahomes josh
allen
now justin herbert these guys who had
that wrap on them
it's actually working out you know and
the guys who
may have a little less physically baker
mayfield another example of it
i think i've struggled to make the
transition a little bit more it's an
interesting dynamic and it feels like a
shift to me
and i think that the dolphins have to
consider that you know again like
i really believe like what brian flores
and chris greer do
like it's amazing what they've done in
two years and i think they have to take
into
account you're not going to be drafting
that high again and so you have to make
sure
that you are locked in on tua because
there's nothing more important than
getting that right
and you know say they come out of this
and it's like okay like we've decided on
tua
and then you know you're getting to 10
wins year after year but you don't have
that quarterback who
put you over the top how are you going
to feel about having taken like a jamar
chase or a micah parsons or a pine soul
or whoever it is
over justin fields or zack wilson that's
why i think you have to if you're the
dolphins
look at those kids versus tua like
actually put them up on the board and
say okay
what does this guy look like what does
this guy look like as an nfl player
versus what is two will look like as an
nfl player he's albert brier
the uh senior nfl reporter the mmqb
and uh nbc sports in boston i don't know
if it was tongue-in-cheek
but mclovin brought this up and said you
know we should have albert breer on
because prior to the game
you sort of made reference to hey if the
eagles
lose this game they go from ninth in the
draft to sixth in the draft
and you showed a picture of devonta
smith are you being
funny no i i think that there was
put it this way i i think that the
decision on the way they handle that
game was organizational i don't think it
was doug peters
peterson's alone and i think the
awkwardness
of it the awkwardness of the way that
that happened
um i think absolutely calls into
question the way this was handled it
looks sloppy
and i think you can make the argument
too dan this is easy an easy argument to
make right like
if that happens in a one o'clock game do
we notice it maybe not
right like the fact that it was on that
stage on sunday night the 256th game of
the year and all of that played into it
but you know i i i think the handling of
the 17th game the handling of week 17
for the eagles
was an organizational decision and doug
peterson's execution of it
i think you know absolutely calls into
question what their motivation was
especially because
this is a three-point game again if
washington's leading by 14 points there
we're not talking about this right
it was a close game jason kelsey had
said what he said last week
and i do think the front office is
cognizant of where they're picking
and what could be on the line again
three draft slots
and you know you can kind of wave your
hand at that and say it's not a big deal
well what if they've decided internally
and i don't know this but what if
they've decided internally
we might be moving on from carson wentz
we want to look at the quarterbacks
that could be huge right like now all of
a sudden if you're at six
not only could you take a quarterback
there now you're in range to go up and
get one maybe a two
if the just decide they're moving that
pick so there's a lot of work
like things where having the six pick
would give you flexibility and i do
think again
organizationally there was a decision
made on how they were going to handle
that game
wow well then i wonder if howie roseman
who's the gm
will step up and because doug peterson
looks
awkward at these press conferences when
he's asked about this
and and you know even when he was saying
like who made this decision
and he fumbled around he didn't know how
to answer it so i
i think that there's credibility to what
you're saying that
maybe it was out of his hands it just
didn't make sense and you're right i've
said
you know after the fact if it's a a
standalone game
everybody has an opinion everybody
um and if you want to start nate
sunfield start him
nobody nobody cares but you go hey we're
down three
this isn't tebow time i mean yeah we're
making it seem like oh
you know what i've waited as long as i
could we're bringing in nate sedfield
and he's gonna lead us
yeah to the promised land let me get a
couple of things here the rams situation
uh when are they going to find out
who their quarterbacks go or does maybe
sean mcveigh know who his quarterback is
i think sean mcveigh knows that
quarterback is i mean i i talked to um
i talked to john walford after the game
um on sunday and he said to me that
like he really knew last week like
monday or tuesday and i don't think it
got out until much later in the week
but like they like he had been given a
heads up and it's like maybe
jared can go but we're gonna prepare for
you to start and so
i think it's the same sort of situation
i like i think
if this was a regular season game i
don't think jared goff would play
obviously the playoffs make put put a
put a you know different
layer of of of intrigue on all of this
my guess would be they're going to get
john wilford ready to be the starter
with the hope that maybe jared goff can
go but again
the way it worked last week i like john
wolford knew really early on
like this that this was going to be his
show and it wouldn't surprise me at all
if the rams have a very very strong idea
of which way this is going
and that john wolford and jared goff
have an idea
too because they're the ones who have to
prepare for it and then washington
they're going to alternate how do you
alternate quarterbacks in the game
against tampa
i think more than i think more than
anything i i saw what ron said i think
this is going to be about there's going
to be a feel thing for them
um what happened in that game so they
get off to the 10-0
lead and my understanding is like alex
got sore and it locked up on him a
little bit like the
the calf did and it affected his
mobility it affected their play calling
and so i think they're gonna go into
this with the understanding at least
like alex we love what you've done if
you can do it we're gonna give you the
best shot to do it
but we have to do what's best for the
team and so
you know they have more confidence in
taylor heineken than i think a lot of
people realize their offensive
coordinator
uh scott turner had heineken both in
minnesota and carolina so there's a lot
of background there
so you know i think this is going to be
a feel thing and
i think the under they understand the
nature of the injury is such where
alex like doesn't really know right now
how it's going to feel on sunday in fact
if you want to go back to week 16
and you know that whole thing with
haskins and everything else
like on friday alex thought he was going
to play they worked him out
on saturday it like it got sore and they
made the decision okay like it doesn't
look like he's going to be able to play
we've got to make the switch
now and we'll see if he can go on sunday
morning but they expected to go forward
with haskins at that point
i think it's gonna be the same sort of
thing this week where like he feels
better
than he did two weeks ago probably he'll
feel better than he felt last week but
they at least have to give themselves
the out where if it
if it causes him some problems again
over the weekend i think they play
saturday night
right like if it causes them a problem
on set if it causes them a problem
saturday where it's going to affect
their play calling the way they run
their offense
they at least have the second guy ready
to go great stuff albert we appreciate
you joining us as always thank you
awesome thanks dan enjoy the game this
weekend that's albert brier senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist for the
mmqb
and nbc sports boston